[Music]
everybody's known for their
collaborations we're hearing about a
bunch tonight music videos who's your
dream collaboration that has not
happened yet my dream collaboration is
Darius Rucker Charles Kelley and Jason
Aldean who I'm actually collaborating
with tonight okay that's a great way to
promote but I mean when you have it done
yeah
my thing is kind of the song and the
moment dictates it it's hard to say I
mean obviously with Lionel and Katy you
know me and Katy may have something in
the works one day would be fun me and
Lyle Lyle and I've actually recorded
stuff that didn't make it out yet so we
got it oh this is big news is it gonna
make I don't call the big news I call
that big news
no we it was some stuff on it was
something that Lionel was working on but
it just didn't it didn't it was a couple
years ago but is it gonna come out I
doubt it
I don't know Lionel ran out of money
what's up with you and Katy and Lionel
together is that gonna be we never know
but uh you getting me in all kind of
trouble I'm gonna wake up in the morning
you in trouble all the time I'm learning
that what I say to you affects my coffee
the next morning
[Music]
[Applause]